le ministre des finances admet que le
projet pilote visant à imposer la tvq
sur les produits achetés à l'étranger
un succès très mitigé des agents de
revenu québec ont été déployés dans des
centres de tri de postes canada pour
contrôler les marchandises
mais ce système ne fonctionne pas
vraiment de sorte qu eric girard dit
qu'il faudra trouver d'autres solutions
par contre la perception de la tvq sur
les services intangibles comme netflix
et spotify fonctionne bien selon le
ministre cela dit on consomme toujours
plus en ligne est toujours en grande
partie chez amazon le cefrio publié
aujourd'hui sur nouvel indice du
commerce électronique du québec une
enquête portant sur plus de 13000
transactions en ligne effectué d'avril
2010 8 à mars 2019 par 500 adultes
québécois âgés de 18 ans et plus on n'a
pas tout de suite avec claire bourget du
cefrio pour son âme bourget si on se
donne d'abord un ordre de grandeur quand
on parle des achats en ligne
ça ressemble à quoi ça ressemble à quoi
par rapport aux autres types d'achat on
pourrait dire de façon générale tout le
secteur commerce de détail en russie on
parle de croissance par exemple
annuellement le commerce de détail va
chercher 2 % à 3 % peut-être parfois 4%
d'augmentation annuelle le commerce
électronique pour sa part chez certains
détaillants sépare aller chercher du 25
pour ça mais peut-être façon générale ça
joue autour de 10% mais c'est clairement
en croissance
c'est très un croissant et donc on va
regarder tout de suite des graphiques
qui se trouve dans l'état du commerce
que vous avez présenté aujourd'hui
l'état du commerce électronique premier
graphique c'est qu'ils sont les cyber
acheteurs
oui alors ce qu'on observe c'est que les
cyber acheteurs sont assez jeune on
n'est ce pas alors mes 24 ans 81 % 25 34
ans 80 % achètent en ligne c'est ça
exact mais le ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on observe dans le groupe des
35 à 54 ans c'est quand même trois
adultes sur quatre qui font des achats
en ligne 73 exactement donc là où les
les pourcentages de cyberacheteurs sont
moins élevés c'est chez les 55 ans et
plus
mais par contre d'année en année c'est
là qu'on voit que les croissances sont
plus élevés donc ça devient acheter en
ligne ça s'est beaucoup démocratisé
c'est un comportement exactement
humaines chez les 65 ans et plus
on est quand même à 30 % donc de plus en
plus de gens qui sont sur internet qui
vont sur internet et qui font confiance
à même internet pour faire des achats d
exact ok 2ème graphique qui ça c'était
les cyberacheteurs le 2ème graphique
c'est qu'ils sont les cyberacheteurs
chez les femmes chez les hommes et les
ménages composés de quatre personnes est
plus exact ce convoi mans dans un
premier temps les hommes achètent plus
en ligne que les femmes 69 % contre 59
exact différents 10% d'un point de vue
statistique la ccl significatif pourquoi
pourquoi je ne pourrais vous dire parce
que les femmes quand même on achète on
est les vols magasineuse mais ce qu'on
voit sur internet les hommes jusqu'à ce
jour sont achètent davantage et ce qu'on
voit ici à droite au niveau des ménages
qu'on voit c'est à partir du moment où
il ya des enfants
on parle de ménages avec enfants c'est
80% où on va acheter en ligne puis on
l'a récemment long avec l'alimentation
ligne droite les familles achètent de
plus en plus en ligne leur alimentation
tout ce qui tout ce qu'ils aillent de
finalement à faciliter la vie de tous
les jours au niveau de la famille ça se
reflète dans nos chiffres
maintenant quelles sont les catégories
de produits qui sont achetés en ligne
vous aviez dit vous étiez une bonne
magasineuse vêtements chaussures bijoux
accessoires exact on voit que cette
catégorie est la principale catégorie
dans laquelle les gens vont acheter des
produits en ligne
est ce qu'on observe également par
rapport à la mesure de l'année
précédente
c'est
des catégories où il ya le plus de
croissance avec 6 points de pourcentage
de plus de plus et donc 38% des produits
achetés en ligne ce sont des chaussures
des vêtements des bijoux ses 38 % d
acheter des adultes québécois qui ont
acheté dans cette catégorie là il y en a
de plus en plus il y en a de plus en
plus en alimentation santé et beauté
exact on voit aussi que c'est l'une des
catégories où il ya le plus de
croissance que plus de croissance au
cours des dernières années et il y aussi
voyager transparent où on affiche une
croissance mais important dans sept
points 2,7 points de pourcentage puis
toutes ces catégories là ensemble
représentent les principales catégories
dans lesquelles on achète le plus et ce
qui domine toujours ses amazones oui
amazon est en croissance pour ce qui est
du nombre de produits achetés au moins
un achat en ligne
on a juste le deuxième il y en a toute
une liste mais c'est pour montrer que
dès le 2ème libé c'est loin derrière
exact donc amazon est passé de 38 à 44 %
des cyber acheteurs ayant réalisé au
moins un achat sur le site et dans les
montants dépensés en ligne amazon est en
tête également exact n'ont pas ce que ça
veut dire à 44 pour ça le si on arrondit
c'est presque un adulte sur deux qui sur
une base mensuelle au fait au moins un
achat en ligne sur amazon puis toutes
les autres les autres sites que nous on
est en identifier notre palmarès arrive
beaucoup beaucoup en dessous avec amazon
est dominant est toujours en croissance
dans sa domination également et quand
j'achète sur amazon.ca est-ce que je
chute au canada bon ça c'est une
question intéressante on achète on
achète d'un site américain on sait qu
amazon est un site de propriété
américain mais souvent les gens vont
maintenant il ya un point ca
les gens ont tendance à croire que ou à
penser que c'est un site que c'est un
site canadien ce qui n'est pas le cas
ce qui ne veut pas dire non plus car on
paie pas de taxes peut pas de tps tvq au
québec ça c'est un autre sujet mais ce
qu'on observe c'est que les gens
achètent
beaucoup plus aux états unis achètent
plus aux états qu'est ce qu'ils en ont
la perception et on pense qu'on achète
au canada mais dans le fond je trouve
exactement comme si tout un défi pour
les entreprises québécoises les
détaillants québécois en ligne on
imagine oui puis surtout avec la
dominance d'amazon ce que ça veut dire
pour les détaillants québécois c'est
qu'on doit s'organiser pour avoir une
prestation de service pour avoir une
qualité de service qui est un peu
équivalente à celle d'amazon parce que
les consommateurs ils s'attendent à
recevoir la même chose c'est ça change
pas d'une année à l'eau alors la suite
sur le site web du cefrio
n'est ce pas l'état du commerce
électronique au québec madame bourges à
merci [ __ ]